[SINGING]
One day, I got a call
from Evan Ziporyn--
a friend of mine and colleague
and composer at MIT--
and he said that
he was approached
by Sanjay Sarma of
Open Learning to see
if he could create some
kind of musical experience
for MIT's virtual commencement.
[SINGING]
Just to fool around
with it, I just kind of
wrote something really quickly--
just as a basic
proof of concept,
like, how about
something like this?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And sent it to [? Eran. ?] And
he went, oh, that's perfect.
Let's just use that--
which never happens.
It was really important
to me that we could
have every person contribute.
And of course, this
is a musical project,
which means that probably,
people who are musicians
are going to feel
more comfortable.
[SINGING]
But we really wanted everyone to
feel comfortable contributing.
And so, we did an analysis of
all of the notes in the piece
that Evan wrote, and figured
out which ones would be harder
to sing, but which ones
might be easier to sing.
And so, on from the
submissions website,
anyone can pick their level
of comfort or experience.
And then the system
automatically gives them
notes to sing that are
appropriate for their comfort
level.
[SINGING]
For everyone who
submitted out there,
you don't really have to
worry about whether you
were singing exactly in tune.
We kind of fixed it for you.
[SINGING]
OK.
Hey everyone.
Getting the team together
to make it happen
was essential, and was,
quintessentially, MIT.
Because I think MIT is one
of the few places where
you think of a project
like this and you go,
OK, we're going to
need a composer working
with Joel Roston.
We're going to need
fantastic audio people.
We're going to need the most
amazing coder on the planet.
We're going to need
fantastic web developers.
fantastic video people.
We're going to need fantastic
communications people who
will get the word out.
And all these people are a phone
call away or an email away,
and will answer.
And everybody is devoted to MIT.
Close to you.
But if the faces are
still coming out--
And I still remember
the first meeting,
when we started to
get people together.
And we're talking
about the website
that we would need to get
the input from participants.
And we're all going, oh, god.
That sounds so complicated.
That's going to take two
weeks just to get that up.
And Ike, just very
softly, says, I'll
have it ready by
2:00 PM tomorrow.
And then he did.
One of the neat things is
we had this feedback box.
And we intended this to be this
piece of the website did not
work well.
But actually, instead,
in the feedback box
we started getting these
comments like, hey, man.
This is awesome.
Way to go, [? Eran. ?]
Hooray for MIT.
It was incredible to see that
people really did contribute.
And you could see,
every minute or so--
every 30 seconds
or so at the peak--
there'd be another
clip showing up.
[MUSICAL SOUNDS]
One of the really
wonderful things I noticed
was that people
were being creative
with how they submitted.
[MUSICAL SOUNDS]
Ti.
[LAUGHTER]
And we also saw a lot of
families coming together.
[SINGING]
And it was really
wonderful to see
a sense of community,
even when we were just
asking for a single note.
[SINGING]
If this were just a
song that was sung,
it wouldn't be quite as
interesting or as challenging.
A really fascinating
part of this project
has been the effort of
putting the video together
with the music.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The visuals for the piece
were left really open ended,
which was wonderful.
And the idea of sort of
a journey came to mind.
The idea of sort of
creating this journey
that the student takes every
day as part of this piece,
really, I thought resonated
with this idea of students going
through their commencement and
through their actual academic
journey.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
There's a part of the
piece that I wrote where
the music kind of ascends.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
When I wrote it, I wasn't
thinking of anything.
It was just something I felt
that was needed musically
at that time.
But what was really magic
to me was when Clayton first
showed us that moment that
the camera crosses Mass Ave
and would walk up the stairs
into the infinite corridor.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
And it mashes the music
absolutely perfectly,
and it made the music work.
It got-- it was the
magical moment for me.
That's the real sign to me of
a great collaboration, when
you do what you do
as well as you can,
and then somebody else
does what they do.
And they take what
you've done and turn it
into something bigger than
what you thought it could be.
There was this discussion
early on about trying
to hide some MIT Easter
eggs inside the piece.
At the time, I was
thinking, you know
it'd be good just to
get the piece done.
Let's worry about
Easter eggs later on.
But we did put four different
moments inside the piece.
And we're excited
that people might
find them and share those.
I think the most heartwarming
part of this project to me
is the fact that it
really is the voices
of the graduates of 2020.
And these are MIT
students who have
put their heart and
their expression
into this musical piece.
And therefore, this is really
a creation of the students,
by the students, and
for the students.
[MUSIC PLAYING]